yep
okay hello everyone Welcome to our
second design review of the day this one
is about machine learning
okay let's take a little look here
so we've we did a review fairly recently
if Dex summarized didn't we yes so most
of what we
discussed was implemented like this week
if you if you want to look at the
documentation page I think it's going to
be is yeah is look it's fine if you look
at the page because we I modified that
with what we discussed last time
uh which it seems you don't have updated
documentation
oh gosh not again
okay can somebody trace this perhaps
before the third design review of the
day
does anybody here can chase that please
I can ask to get your docs updated yeah
yeah
I don't know why it's not working
okay so how are we going to look at this
uh if you want I can share or like
what could I would prefer
well
you could just update the documentation
like you well I know but I mean this
okay whichever right away no no I'll do
that I'll go ahead and do that I just
thought it was done
okay
foreign
what's going on here so
okay so basically we are keeping this
um release externally is quite slim
because we are doing a lot of work under
the hood
um especially around statistical
functions and and and and modeling
function that's so that they can not be
modernized and work with the the new
tabular stuff so uh that is com is
ongoing at a good point
yes yes this is okay so we can start
here
okay
okay so changes like uh there's normal
property the topic specification has
been moved to the first argument
um here we need to do at some point the
final decision I put synonyms in the
like between abstract and description
summary and rewrite and then I
implemented more things that we
discussed
others are coming so
still
I'm just going to get some random piece
of text
oh how do I get the text version of this
uh most of the stuff came in today so I
I don't know how much you have but if
you want to try the older the older spec
that's gonna work so like the summary
and abstract
they are gonna work so the default one
we have no summarization other than one
done through an external llm
right now North
we discussed this at the beginning we
don't have like immediate alternatives
to do that
okay but so we have the service
connection stuff coming that's going to
support zillions of uh available this is
what I said that that's coming for for
the past that's coming for 13-3 we have
a clear release plan and we are also
going to release
um
uh well three with the with the new
release we are going to have open AI
we're gonna have a cloud by entropic and
you're gonna have Problem by by Google
which is a kind of a officially okay
we're also getting the llama and Vulcan
and all these we have support for again
face so you can you can get the you can
get those and we can start registering
those I mean we are finalizing the
administration framework this week uh it
seems to work
so Rick is is switching to that for the
chat notebook and I'm gonna switch uh
for which thing
we we basically we create an abstraction
layer that's going to be used by chat
notebook LM synthetized and so Rick is
already working on important notebook to
use that so that thing is moving very
fast and at that point
we can register things ourselves and
push out packlet updates to add new llms
but we can also make very easy for users
to you know pick their own you know
register it and have it in the in the
interface so they can select it in short
notebooks and use it okay okay let's
talk about this okay we went through a
long discussion last time neither of
these is the right term for this
you can't say
no I mean
we went through this a great length last
time what did we conclude
on the notebook I have this
abstract but it's not that clear it's
better to use description and same for
summaries but it's usually right well do
I put into somebody needs to go listen
to their recording then because we we
discussed this at Great length
okay I go through the recording again is
it okay
yeah I look at this landscape it's
probably better I'm sorry this is just
not right I mean okay you know we went
through this
great great length
and that style yeah I think I I missed
at the end of the discussion apparently
uh
because this isn't right
you know this is
yeah no I mean you can't have one of the
things that Tech summarize does is to
produce a summary
yeah the new synonym is there it's
called rewrite
I'm gonna drop the first one I just I
left the old one as a as I don't think
it's right I'm sorry
than I do
what we concluded
is that what we concluded
yes and then we got other feedback from
members in the audience from that live
stream
we have yet to follow up with that
though
yeah I have more in mind to be
implemented like the ballot lease and
stuff but
um
I mean
and I don't think this is particularly
if
so come on let's let's avoid the typos
here summarizes
generates a summary or you know but this
says summaries right that isn't right
yeah sorry
I should yeah I have to reread this but
this has not been dqaed so far no I
understand
and uh my my eyes and I understand I
don't understand what the order of
things listed here is it's just
alphabetical order yes no it is it was
alphabetical order and as soon as they
remove up certain summary and we
research it so uh okay
those are dresses as a comparison
no this is not a good idea that when it
says paraphrase and then it says in the
same style paraphrase I would expect to
be in the same style
oh well I can just fix it in the
description like give it sure but yeah I
don't know what this should be called
right I mean this is
and we've talked about again the text
discusses this is just what it says
you see what I'm saying yep
how is that reflected here
What description easy text discusses
and and rewrite is one that keeps the
same tone
which in your version is still called
summary so if you want to try it and
check the difference you can say tax
summarize on the same string with
summary and uh and see
what it would say
ah
yeah
which also doesn't have autocomplete
no I I need I need I have a PR in
another report for that okay
which one is this
this is this would be called rewrite
and he's done the
uh is is done the shortening with the
same tone and the one above is what they
call description and it's doing in this
text blah blah blah all this text does
this and that well that's not terrible
but then for God's sake write this
correctly
description of you know
yeah
description of what the text says
rewrite of the text in the same style
okay okay
and I I would not put a verbs here I
would put nouns here
okay so yeah key sentences from text
yeah keywords but that makes sense yeah
okay I'm all right I this is probably
okay I mean we should just check if if
that was what we concluded last time
then I think we should consider it okay
I can verify that as well later okay
well the other big theme that is coming
out is what we dropped with cut the llm
um update to custom and arbitrary lens
for uh just talked about that yeah
that's that's great but we just talked
about it okay let's move on here to
Netflix Journal object
yeah so this thing here we we are
deploying right now Huda there was a bit
of work on reside because we uh we
decoupled the Cuda uh library from mxnet
and uh so you don't have to download it
twice for mxnet and for this one here
um
and uh and we are just testing basically
everything is working on uh on the
packlet downloads before pushing
everything so but Cuda works and now
Mateo is the is working hard on
finishing the core ml so we can have the
the support for for Mac but yeah I think
the thing will be ready okay so what
this means in practice is you can in the
neural net repository we can have things
which are alien creatures any alien
onyxes going around on the on the
Savannah or wherever onyx's live
mm-hmm
is that right so we can already we can
already have these those in the in the
net repository if we want to what is
this now they're fast the advantage is
that we you will be able to use Target
device GPU with net external object and
that will work on a Mac as well I see
that's very interesting right
this is super super important also for
our internal use of of networks yeah
because uh we can use this uh to have
GPU acceleration to like Implement so
does this mean the core ml support does
that extend yes to our own
you know any neural net that we
currently have can now have Target
device you know Arrow GPU on a Mac and
it will work is that correct if we if we
export it to one I mean the only caveat
is we need to be able to export it to 1
and X which we I think almost all of
them we can
uh for example all of our
I don't know image identify and all
those kinds of things
right exactly we could we could redeploy
them as on our next files and then uh
and then import those on the Mac and uh
and run them on GPU
okay but I mean So the plan is to do
that for all of our internal models is
that correct by internal models I mean
models that are in the the product
deployed for a variety of purposes yes
yes exactly exactly as soon as soon as I
have confirmation that this works I'll
I'll start uh elaborate the model that
we used in the neural net Repository
I think so and most of them are
documented we have an ongoing effort to
document all of them
okay
so
something tricky but that would be
immensely helpful given that we have
this as a primary deployment route is to
add the encoders and decoder support to
net external object
because right now this is very naked you
know it's just direct access to the to
the metal
so you you need to to do the you know
image decoding yourself and uh or
whatever it is yeah so I mean you can
still use the encoders and decoders we
have examples in documentation you can
you just use them as a function instead
of attaching them but it would be easier
if you could only import the
just specify you know like this port
named blah blah blah in this network is
an image
right
well this will reduce errors and stuff
so yeah we are also actually working on
this and uh I have I have a branch open
it's just a bit tricky with the way the
criminal currently is but uh I would
like to release this for protein as well
sounds good to me
um okay so just so I understand I mean
in
if you've built a network in our system
and then you export it as onyx
yes then this is saying that I could run
it natively on can I run it on iOS
natively
through core ml
well I mean we do have networks exported
with coramel uh running we we are trying
to for our our math detection uh we are
helping the people doing that app to do
uh formula data detection using core ml
but this is using this using let me use
increment directly though we exported
the network to coramel directly so
honestly the the answer is that I don't
know I'll have to check because this
relies on the on X runtime so your next
runtime of course works on Mac I don't
know if it works on iOS
iOS okay
well okay but I mean so what is the
tooling around getting a
uh an independently running core ml
inference system
I mean do you just output a file we need
to we need to Define an export uh
I I haven't looked too much into that
yet if it is priority I'll I'll I don't
know I don't know I mean I don't know
how useful it is I mean I'm I'm you know
is the bottom line that there's a DOT
onnx file that has that unfills itself
into a giant thing that can be used to
run inference
on some
you know
device or how does it work
well I mean we targeted Windows Linux
Max for now so I have to investigate how
this works on mobile devices how does it
work on a Mac for example
we have it on next runtime uh right now
it's built with CPU support and and the
plan here is to build your GPU support
so basically the only next runtime will
run it on the neural engine instead of
yeah I got that I got that but what I'm
asking is if I want to make this
Standalone okay and I just say I've got
this network look you know let's be
concrete okay so if I say net model
you know Lynette for example okay here's
another here's a model if ever it comes
up come on what's it doing okay now I
want to I want to save that and run it
natively on my machine how do I do that
do I say export basically export or the
that to comma o n and X for the next
exactly and then oh what is this
you need a file right oh yeah sorry see
let me always forget about the file
now let's just do an export string just
so I see what it is oh dear
what
hopefully it's not too big
it is too big and we just crashed
I think it's ready for the long string
what's that
oh it crashed nice it crashed yeah
so that's something that's gonna be a
very long string I would try with export
if you don't if you really wants it but
anyway this will generate in our next
file and then you can use it on next
runtime directly on your on your
computer if you want
what is your end game here
what do you want to do how do I do that
how do I create a temporary file
create file
okay
and you can just put create file in
there if you want or whatever yeah
well I have to give it a DOT on X no no
it is if you say the comma 1 and X it
will take care of it
I want to get the mime type messed up
I have no idea let's try
I just crashed
did it yep interesting
okay so this wasn't a successful test no
this wasn't but I mean I know it won't
show because I spent I spent a week I
spend a week helping Marcus
straightening out his Pipeline with the
segmentation models yeah this creates
definitely most definitely in in master
creates uh our next file and then if you
want to use it from our stock you just
do uh you just import that as an
external object and I'm adding direct
import using the head so you can just
just do Netflix and object of file and
that will create the net SM object for
you
um and why isn't it just net model a
file
because net water is used to download
stuff
this is what this is the file on your
computer is is not not a resource I
understand that but it would know I mean
I I don't think there's anything
ambiguous about net model of a file
doing I mean what's the difference
between net external object and net
model
well net essential object is in Alias
for the resource system so it's
basically doing resource data
for that
yeah
you said that external object net
external object oh sorry yeah sorry net
model is an areas for resource Data
Network search is a wrapper for a
representation on an X model in in our
memory
right so it doesn't get converted it
doesn't it doesn't work no I understand
I understand and the idea is to support
other
types of network frames so it's some
random binary Gunk yes
that has a you know a runtime binary
okay so that's Gunk runtime
it's a managed Library expression right
to be preset yeah okay fine okay but
then
foreign
but if we saw a file which was a DOT on
an x file inside net model it would not
be ambiguous
or nx5s through we already tried that
you can even distribute networks and
logic directly as a serialized
expression we also tried that
so you can basically do net model Foo
and you get automatic Center object
whilst four is probably uploaded to to
our cloud
for example image identify is called the
Wolfram image and Define net V2 yeah so
if if we do I don't know wall from
segmentation net V1 and that
wraps you know is an alias for a net
external object instead of a net chain
or a net graph it will still work the
same okay next question on these
different devices
random you know iOS device Linux device
whatever
you know if I feed in a DOT on an x file
like for example with standard mime type
openers and things if I you know put a
gif file on on a random device it's
going to open with a gif viewer
right yeah
but now with an on an x file I want it
to open
I want it to
become an inference engine that takes
certain input and processes it but how
does it know where to get the input from
in other words what is the Standalone
driver
on you know I've got this file it is a
neural net
how do I
put a harness around it so that it works
on a random
like within a note within the ultimate
no no no no no we're not within our
technology stack what exists okay uh
well you could you use the Onyx runtime
directly you install a runx runtime and
then you say whatever they use I
actually don't know the details about
how to use it
but that's great but it doesn't put the
harness around it particularly
no no you will have to do some console
command like I don't know like load this
file and pass this input
right so so okay so
but that's not something we I mean like
for Arduino for example we provide a
harness
do we not
when you do a microcontroller
programming thing
we you know I could have an Arduino that
actually controls my thermostat or
something yes
because it has enough harness around it
to do that so I'm just trying to
understand if I want you kind of need to
say
on which pin or whatever
um as it's called there right the the
yeah in the Arduino case yes right but
so the question is where's the data
coming into this thing it's running you
know there's a there's a disembodied
neural brain running on the iOS device
and something is speeding data into it
and then it's running its inference and
it's blurting out the output to
somewhere we haven't
I think that that's really useful to
think about sort of that to me is like a
deployment model yeah like I think we
need lots of them for for stuff that we
develop here well I I know but I mean we
have Standalone look for example you
know we have this whole framework which
is
almost arriving
for Standalone deployment of water
mentions
okay
I'm just trying to understand you know
like for example
uh
you know the Wolfram script rapper is an
example of something which provides a
command line wrapper for our technology
stack right so I could imagine a similar
command line wrapper for you know an
onyx inference engine
does that make sense
I don't know command line well maybe
well I mean it's just one one one mode
or or it's a library that plugs I mean
some other thing yeah so I don't have a
super good idea for how one would do it
on iOS what that would be
yeah
I mean it has to be some something that
you write code for from an IDE I assume
Swift seems to be a good thing that it
should hook up to yeah right
but I have no idea but go ahead
but I think that there are other such
similar modes like
how can you export it to be an API on
AWS
or a service on AWS
yeah I know right
I mean just like we've obviously we did
a great job many many years ago with you
know with our API mechanisms and so on
right
uh
but I mean these are sort of you know
this is mobile and Cloud which are two
sort of nearby
modalities in a way or
environments um
even if we do nothing else right okay
we did do for iOS many years ago there
so we wrote A Blog but I think our you
know how to do it on iOS but I think
um I think things have improved and we
could probably you know do it better
fair enough
and so what did he do he did some
mushroom classification
that blog post and then ran it on his
iOS device developed in Mathematica
foreign
massive documentation updates what did
you change uh open predict new and
compare it with predict
I also have a classify new but
I like classify better
where predict new has more examples but
the the the the notes are the same they
are both updated so
why it's going to two lines on your
machine I tweaked the space all the time
okay I have to make it even smaller
of course that should be on one line
input output
line for what this you see but you see
in no you see in Feature Feature feeder
and then no just below you have class
class you know those should be on the
same line
so we basically we rewrote all the notes
created images created images for every
method and started documenting all uh
basically type of input that you can
give in all the examples so predict is
all pushed
um classify I'm reviewing some but uh
there was a no we we started uh spending
a lot of time on documentation because
we noticed with some like
seriously Lucky in terms of everything
we could do and uh yeah well it's
important
well yeah because people didn't know
that people do some stuff to start
reading bugs and support tickets so
right good
that's a minor thing we added progress
upon we add in progress support and uh
basically every version we are taking
some function adding proper supporting
where do I look for the underground tree
you already look at that we skipped one
release because I'm waiting for some
updates in the tree framework to come in
because I I did custom stuff and we
decided it would be better not to have
custom stuff here
so you see all these new
um well Edge functions
yeah
I just got an update today from Ian that
he is actually working on that and he's
gonna update me again in a couple of
days okay fine
so this is a big thing that we start we
just
started touching the surface of all our
statistical modeling functions that have
been sitting there for for a long time
so what we did is uh I mean I really
wrote the whole property framework so
that we don't have crazy dependency
messages and we can actually extending
and make it possible to add new
properties on the Fly also we know this
could be done with the function
repository or whatever
um and we are started to bring them in
the modern world like different uh input
types support for uncertainty uh in the
arguments that's important for
quantities that's very important uh
there's a lot of stuff that they don't
know about right now yeah and this is
going to be ongoing you know is the
biggest thing is what about the output
making kind of nice blobs for the output
rather than some of the crazy stuff we
had before
oh I can I can definitely change I I
have I have a prototype for that I
didn't put it in for 14 but I can
definitely change that to a summary box
the the I mean the fitted model yeah
yeah yeah no no problem no problem
also one thing that they wanted to to
add and I have and I um I helped them on
my machine but just get you're talking
about summary boxes we have this
expression called discrete indicator
which you know
um if we is basically a way to represent
Boolean values
well you were I do know that name I know
what indicator functions are yeah yeah
yeah so it's it's it's
you know what machine learning people
call a one-hot encoding or dummy
variables like statistics people call it
so if you have a categorical variables
with five values
that's going to result in five variables
when you fit it
okay and the formula we'll have these
discrete indicator functions five times
for the different values yes
which is very similar to our
I mean it's closely related to our Bool
functions and things yes yes that's
basically the discrete indicator X comma
a is basically bull of X equally a yes
but with the difference that also holds
all the other possible values that X can
take
yes then hold
and when it has a list of possible
values exactly things can be assembled
you know it knows what the possible
values are
okay and if something is symbolic it's
neither of those values
so wait a minute I mean
open open the page for it it's called
discrete indicator
this has been around for a long long
time yes I'm not saying he was
introduced to seven
really
yes
I've never used it
I make sure you don't really use it this
is created for you for models yes
it's when you want to see the formula if
you fit if you if you if you've only
used fitting and regression for
numerical variables you've never seen it
if you've had categorical variables you
would have seen it
okay well okay so the best point so my
question is given that we are making
these models massively more useful in
terms of data types and processing and
stuff this thing will pop out more uh
can can I make a pipe setting similar to
root objects for this
I hate the root object type setting
nowadays the new one as well well what's
the new one I mean look
I thought it was greatly approved
we need to lock you in in a room with
itai so you can
because you guys
oh God not this again not this again
come on guys I want to get the freaking
polynomial out
at me the polynomial I clicked here I
get nothing that's no you have a meeting
with ETA and he says he's going to do
whatever it is you guys are arguing
about then you meet every week in other
meetings and yet you okay make sure that
this gets it whoever's doing project
management make sure this gets in the
next meeting make sure this doesn't
escape this needs to be in 14 now this
is wrong please fix it
anybody who's able to communicate that
um
yes no who's project managing here they
are
what project manager is here I will yeah
okay can you run did you understand what
to do here
no I've done this yes no no you didn't
understand what to do so no no no no
yesterday
I will pass it to etai
right we must
I I got it and and it should definitely
not print the polynomial for sure
it should be easy to get but it should
definitely not print yeah that's fine
that's exactly what we're trying to
avoid I don't mind that
yeah but but it should be I agree with
you yeah absolutely completely agree no
argument at all
right this is nonsense I mean this is we
agreed a million times Stephen okay I
don't know why this isn't done I just
don't know I don't know either you can
stay in the same meeting with it I says
it's going to do it and then it's not
done I don't know okay so sorry for
opening this Pandora
and and it will be in 14.
what's that
we will make sure to pass it to either
so that it's important
okay so my question was more about the
visual appearance of this like something
which is more than that has a little
frame around it so it reads and you know
if you see that inside of the formula
yeah sorry please yeah Julio I I really
the way to have those discussion is to
have constructive suggestions instead of
trying to get a free mandate to just do
something because I think one needs to
iterate it's like every time we've
designed this we've had to iterate quite
a few times before it gets
sort of good
do you know what I mean I mean like here
I don't know whether you want to display
the ABC
I you know there's a I don't understand
this a
well that's that's maybe a fortune well
so you know the first thing is this
formula it's like X okay
so when x equals a it's true
you know so you could put in
yeah I mean so I'm going to put an X
here and it'll not evaluate right
exactly okay so now if I say table of
this
you know X
a b c d yeah
sorry yeah
okay
well I mean the obvious thing to do here
would be
if if you think this list is going to be
fairly short
would be to have something where you for
example have this list
foreign
[Music]
I mean this isn't right but but you get
what I'm saying
I I think we should come up with some I
don't I don't think that that's going to
work Stephen because okay it's going to
be many of them
yeah and and the other thing is that I
think that the essential information you
need to sort of know is that so these
things are usually called factors
in a in a in a model yeah okay so so
what you want to know is that if this
factor is like male or female
and that's what you want to stand out
you know this is the male Factor this is
the female Factor
I forgot to put the The Proposal
actually I I had it ready I sent you an
email with an image which is the render
the render thing
okay you know or if you have you know
like the typical
um Quality scale like a five you know
strongly disagree agree
those but you have the variable here as
well so
yeah
it might be called you know a city equal
equal room
yeah that's a tool tip so if you over it
you see it can be Rome uh Chicago or New
York
that's reasonable to me
I mean as a first approximation this
looks reasonable
Roger yeah it looks pretty reasonable
but I still want to iterate on it a few
times it just
um
yeah
want to see some more variants basically
okay I I would also
in the tooltip
I don't see a good reason to not give
the you know the thing is explicitly
discrete indicator blah blah blah
I don't see the reason to hide that I
think I think you might as well because
otherwise it's like what the heck is
this okay I'll do one more Edition with
Roger and and then we can we can some
things for approvals yeah
okay so they're going to be exciting
when all these statistics functions
really are modernized yeah I think I
think is
the next version we put a lot of work
with Summer it's just that there's so
much to do that we think it will be
stronger if we have a you know a release
fully focused on those all right fine I
think we can innovate on every part of
the workflow so the data coming in
uh how you control it how we describe it
first of all so you know what the heck
it does yeah
and secondly what comes out so I think
all aspects of the workflow will improve
and we'll fill in a lot of things
yeah no it it it it it it will deal with
missing's that's another thing it needs
to do that's important yeah yep
all right the net repo
we have a lot of network coming out
still so this is the the least updated
to last month of the the new networks
there's some big heaters here like
stable diffusion uh clip and bleep which
is like for image captioning uh image
classification using sentences instead
of classes
and uh and we have these are we using in
our internal functions
so the one that I think let me see what
is the new net
I don't think we use many of these
honestly the one that we use that we are
we are writing right now the
documentation because they are uploaded
but without uh being public yet is the
new segmentation models
that uh yes Sam exactly
it's a very cool model that basically uh
Sam is there well in the next review
that you have in an hour or something
we'll talk Sam all along oh yeah okay
spoil it
search processing uh review okay
all right so I have a question I mean in
in um
uh you know something like pose
estimation
is there a good reason that we don't try
and just make a function for that
you know we could just add that to
official features or like no no sorry
you don't have one for we don't have one
for full body but I think why don't we
have a function for this I mean it's
what is what is the output from post
estimation
at our summer school and high school
program and so on several people have
used this quite successfully it was
rather straightforward to use and it
felt like a thing that was just a
component that could be used you know
what I'm saying yeah no I'm I'm just I'm
just asking out of curiosity what comes
out you know like
um but maybe it is like facial features
it's a function like that and I don't
have to function very much like that yes
you know it's it's
um let's look at that uh
yeah basically Fisher features we we
built there's a collection of uh busy to
wrap a collection of machine learning
resources around the face analysis
pose estimation this one here yeah
so this give it gives a bunch of things
gives bounding boxes gives
um
she points by type and also segmented by
instance so those are points that come
out there or there is kind of labeled
like me I assume that they are yeah yeah
they they are they are sorted so here
we're just displaying the points as in
the naked input the output sorry the one
below is showing you this like the
segmented basically key points so it's
not just me but it's this knee is of the
same person as this other knee
exactly
so this is doing both object detection
and on object marked as people is doing
the segmentation yeah not just a huge
collection of knees
exactly exactly this is this is this is
quite difficult yes and uh and then of
course you have some parameters to
decide uh you know how much you want to
look around to decide if this needs part
of the same person as the suddenly
I think we should build this into a
system function I think this is
obviously you know they're just lots of
random applications for this
well I can see this like you know even
in video processing or something like
that it would be yeah this could be cool
yeah it could be nice to have this I
mean you know it looks to me like it
needs some packaging and so on but it
looks like it's not far away
and then we
I mean I think the plumbing is already
all in this page so uh this mostly is
mostly the packaging as you said yeah
so question
um
uh
like
speech to text
at this point
how multilingual are our speech-to-text
systems
uh
we okay we added a bunch of networks so
at this point is just it should be just
English but we've added a bunch of
multilingual networks and I know that
Carlo was working on those but that
happened
multilingual transcription I cannot
answer to that sorry
I don't think so but it's possible that
we have recognizes
let's bring that up in the next meeting
Stephen with Carlo
okay
um
all right well looking good anything
else we should go over here
nope
um okay well one thing I can maybe tell
you about is that we have a tentative
plan for uh being able to add new uh
connections already in 33 that involves
uh basically releasing two function
repository functions one that will make
it it like why we are still waiting on
the um service framework redesign we can
just you know Skip the weight and
release a function repository item that
will make immensely easier to create a
new service connection
and then it would we would need like a
sibling function that will take that
connection and say oh you see you can
use this connection as a valid shot
provider and and that will basically
make it uh like register it for a chat
notebook chat object it's LM synthesized
so it can glue itself into the uh GUI
basically
is that correct yeah exactly the idea is
that the GUI will basically use our
registration mechanism and basically
query what is being registered so if you
manually register a new a new provider
in your session uh then it will be
available through the GUI
you know one thing that I wonder about
all of this you know in packlets we have
the ability to register things into the
system
right
that's what packlets do is they yeah one
of the things they do is they've stuffed
pallets in the right place and so on
isn't this the same kind of thing
maybe but I think releasing one package
for issue we already have one packlet
for each service connection
is just a matter of telling the system
to use I mean the satisfaction is
already but I'm saying just as a packlet
can announce to the front end that here
is a new palette stick it in the
palettes menu
right why can't a packlet announce to
the chat notebook system here's a new
you know llm provider stick it in the uh
the appropriate menu
it could the reason why we have this
intermediate layer is that not every
service connection supports every
parameter and there's a lot of renaming
there's a lot of things there around
that so basically that is a middle layer
that tries to do all the translations
necessary
yeah but I mean in the end the
registration you don't want the user to
have to run a registration function you
want no just say package blah blah blah
okay
can happen I mean and
possibly
okay
exactly so stuff is no no stuff is
pre-registered and you know if we want
to add a new system ourselves we can
always release a packlet update let's
say of llm functions that will register
new stuff this system is useful for two
reasons people might want to experience
with their own
you know the one is released today
four organizations might want to you
know Point their custom endpoint on some
Azure like AWS cc2 whatever in that case
you know we are not involved but we
should give them all like Solutions also
can create them yeah so so you want a
registration mechanism that is
independent of us so that people can
actually point to their own private
stuff
I agree but I'm just saying somebody in
a perfect world somebody would make a
packlet
but connecting to you know I don't know
what uh you know uh turtle llm or
something right made by
who knows what
um
you know
then and and that would be a packlet
because there needs to be a packlet to
specify the connection
right but as soon as you pack it install
the packlet it would
attach use the appropriate hook
to attach itself to the GUI for the llm
functions
well that's not a problem because if you
if you know what you know if you have
this legislation mechanism you can put
the legislation code in your pocket and
as soon as the pocket is installed the
registration code runs and that's yeah I
understand but what is the registration
code I'm just saying that we have a way
of packaging registration code in the
packlet repository system or in the
packlet system
I mean there is hard code that you could
use to install a pallet in the palettes
menu but you don't have to use it
because that stuff is automatically done
I think I don't completely know how it
works it's automatically done by the
packlet system
the point is that the apocalypse can
sorry um a palette can be anything and
we are fine in displaying anything but
you know if you create a service
connection that is meant to be used
that's call it as an LM provider then
you know we have a format it needs to
understand LM configuration he needs to
understand our standard message I don't
think it's true that you can have
anything for a palette anyway I I think
somebody should have a discussion
probably with Connor about the packlet
system to just see whether this is
something that should be inserted
as a thing that gets registered through
the packlet system I might be wrong it
might not be useful okay we we have
talked to Connor about this he's on
board with our plan but but maybe we
didn't push enough on this amazing
to just have a packlet as soon as you
type pack and install everything just
works
but you say you can do that anyway
because you can have hard code functions
inside it that install it and hook I
mean I can create a packlet that does it
yeah so all right
I'm making a small point that might or
might not be useful
okay
um
all right sounds good see you all soon
am I gonna I'll probably see you in the
in the next um
yep uh meeting right okay thanks for now
all right okay